sont très réguliers très précis dans
leur poule
je montrais la différence par rapport
de la montagne saint denis est à peu
près 200 joueurs inscrits au tournoi
international
on est on a cinq pays dont des joueurs
métropolitain donc un bel est un beau
panel de joueurs et notamment la
championne de france numéro une
française sashina vignes s warrants qui
est championne de france en titre il ya
deux mois qui est numéro une française
donc et qui est 30e joueuse mondiale qui
est venue faire une préparation physique
aussi ici parce qu'on est partis sur les
sentiers mais parce que la chaîne sur
une tournée en asie pendant deux mois
tout ça c'est un travail de longue
haleine l'aide du conseil général elle
est sur plusieurs plans elle est de la
première aide et l'aide financière donc
un partenariat avec le sénégal sur le
point financier un partenariat en moyens
aussi parce que ben on a pu avoir du
matériel informatique à des mises à
disposition en termes de communication
conseil général nous a mis des sacs pour
tous les joueurs qui ont été offerts à
tous les jours donc un grand merci au
conseil général parce que ça nous a
permis aussi dans l'organisation de
parfaire les petits détails mais qui
sont très importants pour les journées
pratiquement 40 45 mille euros de budget
sur un tournoi comme ça donc c'est sans
aide les des collectivités s'est passé
pas du tout quoi écoutez moi je quand je
vois ça quand on a vu la salle se monte
petit à petit moi j'suis comme un enfant
je suis et j'y crois et j'ai envie que
ça continue qu'on